finir ce volet sur l'ailé sur les
élections législatives nous sommes allés
recueillir les réactions des différents
maires de saint quentin en yvelines
suite aux résultats du premier tour des
surprises des inquiétudes quant à la
composition de la prochaine assemblée
nationale réponse nicolas d'ombrie face
aux résultats du premier tour obtenus
par les candidats de la république en
marche des mers saint-quentinoise sont
inquiet pour le débat démocratique
aujourd'hui c'est un mouvement qui est
derrière le président de la république
et qui lui donne une carte blanche
dangereuse démocratiquement parlant donc
ça m'inquiète
à ce niveau là je crois que la
démocratie notre 5ème république est une
démocratie qui a besoin je dirais d'une
contestation constructive et en tout cas
d'un débat selon don s'aperçoit c'est
surtout en fait que le grand vainqueur
c'est l'abstention
aujourd'hui on voit bien on est dans une
véritable crise démocratique
puis il ya ceux qui ont été surpris par
cette vague balayant les partis
politiques traditionnels
alors je suis bien sûr comme beaucoup de
français surpris par le phénomène en
marche
je ne pensais pas je savais que on
aurait quelques surprises mais à ce
point là je n'imaginais pas et ça se
passe partout en france
c'est un vrai paradoxe qu'on est en
train de vivre parce que je crois qu'au
fond les les gens se sont battus contre
la loi sont battus contre la loi
territoriale
je suis très surpris sur les yvelines
par contre que tous les députés sortants
l'issue des républicains voir ne lui dit
soit en difficulté partout et en cas de
victoire des candidats de la république
en marche dans les circonscriptions de
l'agglomération les élus locaux vont
adopter plusieurs attitudes avec une
volonté plus ou moins importante de
travailler avec leurs députés
en tant que maire on ne trouverait
toujours dans une position de
construction je travaillerai et j'aurai
la même exigence avec le député qui
représentera la première ses conceptions
et je pense que un député sera aussi
obligés de travailler avec le maire de
la deuxième ville de sète et sa
conception
un député c'est quelqu'un qui a été élu
par par les citoyens et moi je suis très
démocrate c'est bien évidemment nous
travaillerions avec cette construction
mais en même temps il va y avoir du
temps parce qu'il faut apprendre à
connaître la circonscription
enfin moi en tant que maire communiste
et avec les élus communistes à la région
au national j'espère on portera nos
exigences avec la députée en marche
comme avec tous les autres il ya des
problématiques à voisins surtout en
terme de circulation
donc les deux candidats en lice se sont
engagés à nous aider sur ces problèmes
là donc j'aurai à coeur de travailler
vraiment dans la proximité avec une
prochain députés quel qu'il soit
prochaine étape pour ces mères issues
des mouvements politiques historiques
les élections sénatoriales prévues le 24
septembre prochain elle pourrait
permettre de faire émerger une
opposition dans la chambre haute du
parlement